yeah pizza you don't want to get  delivered because it gets steamed in the  box and it's all like floppy and stuff  at one time and he was like we have to  throw it away yeah it has to be crispy  like i have to be able to pull a piece  of pizza up if i can crunch it sideways  and and the tip always stays like that's  pizza i want to eat if it just like  flops down like a flaccid you know  that's not the type of pizza i don't  want flaccid pizza since i've been  married we've ordered pizza one time to  the house and then he was like we must  throw this away and then we literally  put in a digiorno because he was like i  can't eat this pizza let's just do the  dijon